well six people are being questioned
after an apparent attempt to assassinate
Venezuela's president with weaponized
drones loud explosions interrupted a
speech by President Nicolas Maduro on
Saturday seven soldiers were injured
officials say the alleged attack was
orchestrated using drones carrying bombs
tonita copal has a look at this emerging
threat to national security in the US
and overseas Tony a good morning good
morning you put your finger on it this
is not just event as well a thing this
is a global thing this is an American
thing as well president Maduro has been
condemned by his opponents who accuse
him of threat of thrusting Venezuela
into an economic and humanitarian
catastrophe in driving hundreds of
thousands of people to flee Saturday's
alleged attack would not even be the
first one staged against a controversial
ruler and his government but here's the
big picture it increases concerns that
drones could be used to help terrorists
here in the US it has all the makings of
a Hollywood film a head of state dodging
an assassination attempt from a drone
that's what Venezuelan president Nicolas
Maduro says happened to him on Saturday
on stage troops used ballistic shields
to protect the president seconds later
state TV cameras showed soldiers
scrambling in response to an apparent
second explosion from another drone a
video posted to Twitter shows a drone
exploding in midair CBS News could not
authenticate the video no tengo Lula
president Maduro who was unharmed says
the incident was an attack on my life he
blamed the venezuelan far right in
addition to the US and Colombian
government's both countries have denied
any involvement the drones in the hands
of terrorists has been a growing concern
among US officials last year The
Washington Post reported Isis used
drones to attack US Special Operations
Forces in Syria in joint testimony
delivered to Congress in June top
homeland security officials called
drones a serious looming threat that the
u.s. is currently unprepared to confront
doesn't take much training and fixing
some kind of explosive to a drone to
fashion a crude weapon Colin Clark
specializes in terrorist insurgency for
RAND Corporation a non-profit global
policy think-tank he says as drones
become more common the interest in using
them for terrorism increases including
in the u.s. this is the new world we're
living in and we've got to adjust and I
think we've got to come up with
countermeasures and speaking of
countermeasures Venezuelan officials say
the two drones in this case were loaded
with about two pounds of c-4 explosives
they were able to knock off one of the
drones electronically the other
apparently crashed into an apartment
building about two blocks away yeah very
scene yeah how to deal with drones
opening up a whole new conversation
it's fascinating Tony to see how quickly
they came out with those ballistic
shields
yeah who knew they even have that
technology I don't you can get that at
RadioShack country's going through an
economic and humanitarian crisis very
serious situation now all right Tony -
Coco always good to see you